understand I I I just I don't get it I
visited the occupied territories Russell
during the first Ina I cried every day
for two weeks been featured by Trump I
love the Muslims I think they're great
people Donald Trump the junor guys Don
Jr here I'm going live and so we get
these kind of propped up people like Ben
Shapiro who Israel kills enough of these
sons of [__] that this is not a
problem Jordan Peterson what happened to
Jordan Peterson when he started working
for Ben Shapiro at the here's the
logical conclusion of that you're your
own church you're your own
God three lives currently being told
about Palestine number Oneal Alum
greetings of Peace welcome to the de
sham media host subscribe if you haven't
already hit that notification Bell so
you don't miss exciting programs like
this one my next guest Keith Woods he's
a independent news source commentator
analysis he's debunking much of the F
fake news that's out there so much so
that he's reported has even been
featured by Trump I love the Muslims I
think they're great people Muslim Muslim
oh absolutely no problem with that would
I consider putting a Muslim American in
my cabinet absolutely no problem with
that you think that Muslims pose a
danger to this country I love the
Muslims I think they're great people
himself that's right Donald Trump the Jr
my guy is Don Jr here I'm going live
tonight we have an exciting new episode
he's brought to light much of the
atrocity propaganda that the likes of
Jordan Peterson are promoting uh by and
also his boss his higher up Ben
Shapiro and it's really unfortunate and
sad to see that much of the stuff that's
being put out there also by our
Christian conservative friends that we
are trying to build actually a
relationship with to unite against much
of the evil that's affecting us our
families and our children do anyone know
what a drag quean is leave our kids
alone
our kids alone leave our kids alone our
kids alone leave our kids
alone man walked into the women's
bathroom at
McDonald's my daughter goes into those
bathrooms and no man needs to be in
there you understand me you are a man
you are created as a man you are a man
start acting like a
man so without further do let's bring
out our special guest Keith
Woods I love
you when I was ready to talk about it I
would only talk to I was explaining how
much respect I have the
of
the hey thanks for having me on good
good to be here good to uh have you with
us how are you Keith how's it
going yeah doing pretty good uh like you
said it's it's been full frontal assault
the last few days there's a there's a
lot of information war going on right
now okay before we get into your
interaction with uh the Trump himself
the junior get is D junor here and I
want to go ahead and let a get your
feedback on this short clip it's
actually by a
Holocaust A holoc Survivor himself is
when he was a child uh who really speaks
about what's going on so instead of me
and you just getting into it I want to
let it come from a holocaust Survivor
himself and then we'll kick it off how's
that sounds good and I found out that it
wasn't exactly like that that in order
to make this Jewish dream a reality we
had to visit a nightmare on the local
population and there's no way you could
have ever created a a Jewish state
without uh oppressing and ex expelling
the local population Jewish Israel
historians has shown without a doubt
that the explosion of the Palestinians
was persistent it was pervasive it was
cruel it was
murderous and with deliberate attempt
so that's what's called a NPA in Arabic
the disaster or the catastrophe there's
a law that you cannot deny the Holocaust
but in Israel you're not allowed to
mention the Naka even though it was at
the very basis of the foundation of the
state I visited the occupied territories
Russell during the first inata I cried
every day for two weeks at what I saw
the brutality of the
occupation the petty
harassment the murderousness of it or
cutting down of Palestina Olive
Groves the denial of water rights the
humiliations and this went on and it's
much worse known than it was then it's
the long it's the longest ethnic
cleansing
operation in the 20th and 21st centuries
I could land in Tel Aviv tomorrow and
demand citizenship under the right law
of the right of return but my
Palestinian F in Vancouver hanas who was
born in Jerusalem can't even visit now
if I have the right to return after
2,000 years how come Hana hasn't got the
right to return after 70 years so then
you have these miserable people packed
into this horrible people call it the
world's largest outdoor prison which is
what it is you don't have to support hos
policies to stand up for Palestinian
rights that's a complete falsity if you
take the worst thing you can say about
Hamas multiplied by a thousand
times and it still will not meet the
Israeli repress I and killing and
dispossession of
Palestinians uh your
thoughts yeah it's it's a perspective we
don't get much in the west uh everything
is is in the context of whatever the
most recent event is all of the focus is
on a specific Hamas crime and we're
totally denied the context of of what's
causing this violence um the fact is
there are over
600,000 illegal Israeli settlers on
Palestinian land tens of thousands of
homes have been demolished by these
legal settlers in the case of Gaza this
is an area that's five miles wide that's
a morning and jog for some people uh 25
miles long with 2.1 million people
packed in there it's one of the most
densely populated areas on Earth half of
them are
children and these people really have
been denied any way of of advancement
here I mean uh what are they supposed to
do you know the whole con ation like I
said in the west has become about Hamas
terrorism um and the focus of of how
Israelis have suffered at the hands of
Hamas but these people are under a
brutal occupation they're under complete
blockade the Israeli government has
turned down multiple trues from Hamas
you know whatever you want to say about
how extreme Hamas is they have offered
trues in exchange for end in the
blockade which have been rejected and
these people are in an absolutely
desperate situation and it is funny um
you know when you hear discussions of
the nakba we're getting all this
atrocity propaganda right now bench P
was was retweeting a claim that there
was pregnant women having their babies
ripped from them no evidence for this
claim at all but a lot of stuff actually
applies to the nakba um there were
children ripped from their parents
during an aqua there were Mass rapes
there were murders of civilians don't
take my word for it I mean we've seen
footage circulating this week of of
former Israeli soldiers this occupation
is an ongoing criminal act of war crimes
after war crimes was a psychological and
um and very difficult process but once
you realize that uh you are part of a
terrorist
organization uh you understand that you
have to say no you have to take the
consequences because I uh say that
Israel is an apartheid state because I
say that my government and my military
commanders are war
criminals
for um that look back on this with Glee
of how they use flamethrowers on
Palestinian civilians how they raped
16year olds
um many of them are proud of this so
unfortunately it's it's a very one-sided
conversation in the west but the context
that's that's always left out is the
fact that you know these people are
being denied statehood they being denied
basic necessities of existence and it's
it's forcing this this brutal
situation I want to go back to what you
were saying I want people to imagine and
I just heard the story yesterday that
someone that a friend of mine a family
member knows that they got word this was
before everything kicked off now that
someone the their family home they had
people coming in they're about to take
over so you have to just get on a plane
and get from over here to over there I
want people to imagine like you got your
home that's been passed down from
generation to Generation generation and
it's been in your bloodline your family
and then you got these illegal this is
by International they're violating
international law this is something that
now can you just imagine this is your
home it's your property imagine a home
you're living in right now just somebody
just came in and just you put you on the
street I mean it's hypocrisy to think
that some people would you know just sit
there you ever seen that movie Red
Dawn I haven't seen that no I I
recommend it's with Patrick uh sey uh
maybe this this is uh not from your
generation but this is a old older movie
and Americans were under attack I think
by Russians or whatnot in the movie and
then they can see they're coming out to
you know protect their Homeland and
whatnot and it seems is very
hypocritical like when people you've
seen videos with the um with the Muslim
lady and then the Jewish shutler said
hey if I didn't steal it somebody else
would you are stealing my house and if I
don't steal it someone else is going to
steal it I don't know if did you see did
you ever see that video yeah yeah I saw
that and the guy has a New York accent
you not even from the region so what I'm
saying is just you got to put yourself
have some empathy some sympathy I mean
we we I mean me as a Muslim um you're a
Christian yeah yeah you I'm kind of a
laps Christian yeah definitely
culturally Christian yeah but I mean as
as a Muslim this is something according
to Prophet Muhammad you know who we
believe is the last final messenger you
know killing any innocent human being
life I just want to put this on there so
I don't know if you've ever seen this um
there's engagement before the Geneva
Convention you know you're not to kill
any innocent men women and children
mutilating bodies cutting down what what
you see in Gaza it's just like a total
Annihilation like all buildings you know
of innocent civilians are just being you
know just bombed annihilated people can
can see um you know and this is one of
those things that you actually with with
with Trump he actually retweeted one of
your
tweets and you you uh made a comment
after that he said they are respectfully
uh graping women shooting uh concert
goers and kidnapping the children they
shoot and blow clut and then you because
you tweeted some you you reported here
can you go ahead get into this uh you
reported of the respect of the churches
all I did was all I did was post this
video of um as retaliation uh the
Israeli forces bombed this very old
mosque in in Gaza one of the the largest
mosques there I believe and I just
pointed out that look if if we're
talking about standards of military
action and so on and and how terrible
the violence is on both sides well you
know Hamas did give orders to their
Fighters uh to respect churches and
monasteries and then you see the
behavior of of the IDF they're happy to
Target religious sites got a huge
backlash but no one actually said it was
wrong um as you as you see with with
Trump himself he he didn't actually say
it was wrong um but you know again this
is this is stuff that's that's not
highlighted it's it's totally different
when you have people are lashing out
basically against being in in an open
air concentration camp uh and in in a
desperate situation where they're slowly
being ethnically cleansed versus an
occupying Army that is now targeting
civilians as far as we can can tell uh
seems to be carpet bombing of of Gaza
there's no way to to believe that these
are sort of precision military strikes
and it's just so ironic because I
remember when the the Ukraine war
started and we were getting this footage
of buildings being bombed in Ukraine and
Putin was being called a war criminal
for this and there was all sorts of
allegations of of Civilian shelling and
these were war crimes um very little
evidence for those specific claims but I
mean we're we're witnessing it happening
every day now in in Gaza MH that's
acceptable it's acceptable if if the
Zionist state does it I just want to
make a caveat here just as as a Muslim
and Muslim simply means um as we go
along I'll just educate the audience
because they hear some of these words
and they're like you know they have
associations that are totally the
opposite Muslim is simply one by
definition who submits his will to the
creat of heavens and earth so as a
Muslim I don't know about much of these
groups in there like most Muslims we're
just you know so hamus or whatever some
of these other you know the groups so
we're what they're trying to do is like
uh this lady here she sees a Palestinian
flag and I think you also I don't know
if you posted on this but you had people
who can identify with what they say is
an occupation from Russia so you see a
lot of Americans putting Ukrainian Flags
but as soon as this lady sees a
Palestinian flag she thinks okay right
away in her mind they're programming
she's connected with hummus or who some
other group out there and she thinks
right away they program you think like
oh you're supporting terrorism you're
this that and the other I mean it's just
absurd so have a have a look at this
streets post it author Lauren wise
that's my Instagram author Lauren wise
you should be ried and dragged through
the streets in front of your kids that's
what you okay thank you you're
addressing Hamas Hamas a terrorist thank
you thank you for your name thank you
have a I think you
should all of you [__] idiots who think
that it's Palestine
I I I just I don't get it I just can't I
don't like I don't you know I I don't um
understand this is what when you see
something I just don't get it uh
Keith well I mean the the media is is
totally one-sided you know we have a
Zionist controlled media in the west um
you know they preach tolerance and
diversity and and open board ERS and all
these these very like leftwing values to
us in the west comes to Israel they
support this this you know farite Li
could government they support the ethnic
cleansing uh they support repressing
this this non-white population it's a
complete double standard this is never
explained you have the head of the ADL
out there Jonathan Green blad purpose of
the ADL is supposed to be to to fight
racism they tried to get tuer Carson
fired from Fox News because he was
speaking out against immigration in the
US at the same time they're support this
this farite Zionist government in Israel
and we have protesters on the streets of
New York I don't know if you saw this
footage um but there's a there was a
protest in in New York by uh these uh
people that were sympathetic to Israel
and they were literally calling for the
complete genocide of Arabs and and
wiping out of Gaza the response should
be from Netanyahu and the military to G
all Palestinians all of them now one
left from The River To The Sea Palestine
will be deceased and Israel need to do
like this see now Gaza like this Gaza
need to do like this oh or like this but
all this Jewish two options what do you
what do you think the response should be
to Gaza we got to wipe them off talking
about every flatten them like a parking
lot yeah flatten them out once get there
anything else you can do I think I think
now it's the time that we need to race
Gaza John green blad is silent in that
because green blad and the ADL of course
are themselves Zionist and they support
the Zionist entity so we see this double
standard across the media um it's it's
never questioned the pro-israel position
is is always taken unfortunately you
know people in the west get that
propaganda from all
sides
uh going going back to your interaction
with uh Trump Donald Trump uh Jr you
pointed out something but I did respond
to Trump Jr with is you know he's
portraying this as because he wants
people in the west to be sympathetic so
it's you know the it's this kind of
Muslim versus Christian conflict but I
said to him well how come you don't
speak out about the treatment of of
Christians in Israel because just in the
past few weeks we've had multiple
stories there was a Christian Cemetery
in Jerusalem that was smashed up by
Jewish settlers uh there was a church in
hia that was occupied by these Jewish
extremist groups they've been forcing
out Christian and Muslim worshippers out
of out of their holy sites in the holy
land with the support of the IDF the
support of of the the KET government and
we've seen multiple videos in in recent
months and weeks of these Jewish
settlers spitting on
[Music]
Christians
as they're doing the Stations of the
Cross through Jerusalem you see these
these Jewish groups spitting on
Christians now you could say oh that's
an isolated incident uh you know every
country has its extremist right but the
problem is in the Israeli government you
have people that are sympathetic to this
the Israeli National Security minister
went on Israeli State TV and defended
that he said look it's an old Jewish
tradition to spit on Christians you know
we should keep that on mind when we talk
about this we shouldn't condemn them too
much
so these are the kinds of people in in
the Israeli government and you know the
background to this that that people are
missing as well
is none of this happens in a vacuum and
there's there's provocations on both
sides certainly but in recent weeks
these provocations have really increased
uh in Jerusalem and there are these
extremist Jewish groups that want to
build uh the Third Temple to fulfill
their prophecy on the side of the aloos
which you can correct me but I believe
that's like the third holy site in the
world for Muslims yes so this is
obviously very very incendiary for the
reestablishment of the Third Temple
there will be a third Temple are already
active the temple Institute in Jerusalem
is active and there's multiple groups
like this that are openly working for
this which would create a huge conflict
one is the the temple Institute is the
third temple being rebuilt I don't have
to guess about this now I've been to the
temple Institute in Jerusalem myself and
I can tell you that all of the furniture
is already prepared the plans are
already in place and now for the first
time in Millennia they are making plans
to rebuild the Temple this is a major
development who its leader of 30 years
actually did a a podcast about this the
other day Rabbi Heim Richmond and he
said that Christians in the west should
be worshiping all Jews I just want to
say this to our Christian friends you
know uh just to just to call it as it is
and say it straight out you know you
guys are worshiping one
Jew that's a mistake you should be
worshiping every single one of us
because we all die for your sins every
single day and that's exactly what's
going on here we're we're all God's
first B we're dying for your sins right
now because because the Jewish people in
the land of Israel are the bul workk
against the
Orcs okay the Orcs are coming not to a
theater near you but to your home again
very extremist like supremacist
statements he said that Israel was
defending the world against the Orcs And
he just casually referring to to Arabs
as Orcs it's like a total supremacist
and these are the the kind of extremist
groups that are driving this you know
they're trying to this Temple Institute
is like trying to breed this um red heer
they're using like embryo selection it's
it's really weird stuff trying to
fulfill these talm modic prophecies and
they've been exacerbating this a lot you
know they were sprinkling Blood on the
side of of the alaa mosque uh kind of
preparing the way for for filling these
prophecies and and doing this
sacrifice um and the problem is you know
it would be one thing if these were just
some weird isolated cult right you have
that in in every country America has
crazy Christian Cults that protest
funerals and stuff right but they're
very much On The Fringe but the problem
is these people get the support of the
IDF when they storm alaxa mosque and
force worshippers out the IDF protects
them hundreds of ultra nationalist Jews
are carrying out incursions into the
alaka mosque complex in occupied East
Jerusalem
big crowds of mostly young settlers
raised provocative slogans and entered
the Moss compound for a third day on
Tuesday to Mark a season of Jewish
holidays they're being escorted by the
Israeli police the tensions have been
rising here because during sukot this
this uh week-long holiday uh alter
Nationals Jews have been entering the
Temple Mount uh which they call the
Temple Mount which others call the AL
oxa uh compound in larger than usual
numbers um and when they make these
extremist statements and they said that
all non-jews should be worshiping them
as as some kind of uber mention just
just to call it as it is and say it
straight out you know you guys are
worshiping one
Jew that's a mistake you should be
worshiping every single one of us um
people in the Israeli government defend
them so if we want to talk about
extremism or we're always getting told
about white supremacy in the west right
the biggest problem ever is is white
supremacy what about the supremacy
that's that's d in this conflict where
you have you have Jewish supremacists
within the Israeli government you can go
through look at the the members of of
the Israeli conit multiple members
cabinet members of the lud government
have expressed their desire to build a
third Temple which means eradicating
these Christian and Muslim holy sites in
the area because they have to destroy
all these Idols as they consider them to
fulfill the prophecy which means
demolishing this mosque that's that's uh
has a very sacred place for
Islam this is a totally extremist
position but it's it's accepted as as
normal increasingly in the discourse in
Israel amongst Israelis and again never
reported on in the
west back to um what you were you were
discussing here that today we are
witnessing the creation of atrocity
propaganda in real time what is atrocity
propaganda and how has it been used to
win support
War uh are we see that with much of this
here this is this an example of it and
much of what these uh people such as Ben
Shapiro Jordan Peterson and the Trump
himself Donald Trump the junor are
sharing three lies currently being told
about Palestine number one 40 babies
were beaded this is completely false no
evidence has been provided for this the
claim comes from this journalist during
a Walkin talk she makes the claim saying
I see in the distance more bodies being
covered babies their heads cut off later
in a tweet however she admits that she
did not see bodies but heard a soldier
talking about it number two people were
raped also false there is no evidence of
this whatsoever much of the atrocity
propaganda that you're talking about and
you've uh you've you've uh debunked a
lot of this stuff is that correct yeah
I've been trying to keep ahead of this I
expected this kind of thing to come out
because this is what they always do in
times of conflict and I would just say
to Muslims as well you know you see all
of these kind of conservative comments
ators in in the west that are promoting
this s these are really AstroTurf
propped up people you know a big part of
this is that there's been so much
censorship across social media that
conservatives and nationalists and
patriotic people in the west that oppose
Wars for Israel that oppose the Zionist
agenda they're just censored off these
platforms so they don't really get a
chance to to push back uh and so we get
these kind of propped up people like Ben
Shapiro who Israel kills enough of these
sons of [__] that this is not a
problem whenever anyone suggests that
Israel is willfully killing Civ ions
that is the most ignorant bigoted
anti-semitic bull ever said there cannot
be a ceasefire anyone who calls for a
ceasefire is a terrorist sympathizer
under these circumstances you know he
doesn't care so much about American
Heritage or culture but he uses his his
last video to try and raise funds for
the IDF he doesn't represent the average
American these people don't represent
the average person in the west but I
certainly expected to see this kind of
atrocity propaganda and in that tread I
go through the history of this you know
it's very interesting one of the first
first examples of this was 1641
rebellion of of the Irish against
English Rule and you saw these reports
in in Britain and the English Parliament
and the early version of the press where
they were talking about the Irish Rebels
were ripping babies from pregnant women
um and you know there were torturing
women and children and all this kind of
thing and these reports were used to
justify a pretty brutal Crackdown and
later crom while executing prisoners
invoked this and it's incredible you see
like identical kinds of stories now when
you see Ben Shapiro to 6.1 million
followers retweeting the claim of of
women being ripped from pregnant
children by by Palestinians so the
Playbook actually hasn't changed much in
all those centuries but we saw some
recent examples of this specifically
related to the Middle East as well I
mean when the US was justifying its its
uh attack on Iraq with the first Gulf
War there was this famous testimony by
this cetti girl who was 15 who said that
she had witnessed babies being pulled
from incubators by Iraqi soldiers and
left to die on the ground and the first
Bush invoked this a lot in justifying
the war these are baby killers these
Iraqi army they they RI babies from
incubators right who could oppose baby
killers uh who could oppose fighting
baby killers rather um it turned out
this girl was actually the daughter of
the cued ambassador to the us and this
campaign had been organized by a front
group a QED Public Relations Committee
that was actually run by an American
peor form so the entire thing was fake
the entire thing her testimony was
pre-planned they beded the story because
it was good atrocity propaganda and note
that they always go for the baby killers
they always go for the children right
who could oppose people that want to
fight baby killers and the point of
these stories is to dehumanize the other
side and it's very important to the
Zionist cause because the way they fight
these wars is they target civilian
populations and if you want to justify
that you have to invoke some kind of
collective guilt on these people you
have to say that these standard sort of
uh Western ideas that have been adopted
internationally about rules of war and
civilian engagement and just War these
don't apply because actually this entire
group of people are guilty and they're
guilty of this Collective evil and the
most obvious way you can invoke that
that everyone is going to agree is is
just morally Beyond The Pale is is is
targeting of children and what do we see
yesterday we see this claim 40 beheaded
babies The Source was uh Israeli News
Network I've yet to see any verification
for this it's been out 24 hours now
supposedly the Israeli Army said that
they have no information about this but
this went all across Western social
media and then we were just getting
story after Story like this there was a
picture that was supposedly of of a
Israeli corpses and and someone
identified that they were actually IDF
body bags which suggested there were
Hamas Fighters uh a video that Donald
Trump junor posted that I actually got a
community note i' kind of fact checked
them which was kind of funny but he was
posting this video of a a room full of
full of corpses and people had just shot
them up and he claimed that a friend in
Israel sent him this and and told him
that this was what Hamas Fighters did
the dead people were were clearly Arabs
and we traced the source of this video
was from
2015 so all this stuff is is going
around social media no one even knows uh
where it's from what the source is but
they're basically just looking for
anything they can find to sck and we've
heard all this about you know Mass rapes
this thing with the Rave and again you
trace the sources for this what's the
the source of of Ben Shiro was posting
this as well that there was 240 people
raped at this R raped and killed well
you know am I a terrorist sympathizer
because I say I'd like to see some
evidence of this um so far what I've
seen as far as evidence for that is it
was like a one eyewitness report so one
person claimed this we've seen no photo
evidence you know it's 2023 everyone has
a camera phone uh especially these these
young people at Raves and in Israel
there's no photo evidence there's no
video evidence there's no corroborating
evidence there isn't even a second
eyewitness that reports this and just
increasingly these stories get debunked
not within hours but within minutes but
they still reach millions of people
because you have these centralized
Zionist influencers in these networks
that prop each other up and pushed us
out there and they do it in a way that
they know will appeal to a western
audience as far as the Rave goes I mean
I saw footage yesterday that there was
actually Israeli police at the Rave that
engaged in a firefight with the Hamas
Fighters and the claim was they were
using the ravers as human Shields now I
don't know if that's true but certainly
they were there covering with them and
between the crossfire so it wasn't as
clear could a picture as as they just
descended on and attacked all of these
civilians but that's not even to defend
that's specific action but it's just to
say that we're not getting the full
story here and people are putting this
out without factchecking it without any
standard of of evidence or investigative
journalism and it's because they support
this agenda it's because these people
are bought and paid for by powerful
Zionist influences in the case of of Ben
chapiro you know he said his that he his
loyalty to Israel is is his loyalty to
the US comes from the fact that they
support Israel so much um and these
people have a clear agenda and it's
clear that they are misleading their
audiences MH we tried to push back
against it but it's just such a like I
said a full frontal assault on on the
information Warfare
front I don't know if you heard of um
UFC fighter one of the uh Legends of the
UFC Jake shields uh I don't know if he
was following you before I recommended
um that he follows you and for some
balanced Fair
reporting and he's also somebody who is
uh
discussing what we're talking about much
of these fake videos it's amazing how
much propaganda and fake videos we are
seeing online social media is making it
easier for us to direct lies but imagine
how much fake history we are taught he
even goes deeper despite that many
countries will throw you in jail for
questioning history soon they will need
to pass laws questioning current
events so it's um he's uh someone also
you mentioned U this term astroturfing
can you go ahead and explain you know
most people don't know what that what
that term mean but but this is really
important that people know this term
astroturfing what that actually is yeah
astroturfing is is when a powerful
interest like props up a kind of fake
entity to represent a cause presenting
it as something else now the perfect
example is what I talked about with the
the cuti baby story yes is you had this
cuti public affairs committee that was
supposedly this kind of neutral
committee that's just reporting on
what's going on in QED it's actually run
by a PR firm that is specifically like
design and strategies for how do we get
the American public to support a war in
Iraq that's the perfect example of
Astrin now what you have to realize
about political discourse in the west is
it's entirely astroturfed and I would
say specifically on the right because
when people gravitate to you know
right-wing or you could say conservative
beliefs in the west I think they tend
much more to have my instincts you know
I want to preserve my identity my
Heritage I'm Irish I share the the views
majority of Irish people you know I
don't want to lose lose my nation to to
this liberal uh globalist uh
Multicultural way of life I want to
preserve the things about Ireland that I
value and I think that's how most
Europeans feel they're really not
interested in in conflicts in the Middle
East and and you know sending weapons
over to to use on on Palestinians I mean
this is this is a hard sell for the
average person what happens is you look
at the conservative movement and you
look at like Charlie Kirk who's the head
of tpusa this big uh conservative
students move in the US and he's funded
by by Zionist billionaires you look at
Ben Shapiro and he's an ENT Zionist uh
he declares his loyalty to Israel and on
every show he's raising money for the
IDF his employee is is Jordan Peterson
and what happened to Jordan Peterson
when he started working for Ben Shapiro
at the daily work here's the logical
conclusion of that you're your own
church you're your own
God you know this was a guy who had a
huge audience captive audience of young
people he he taught them meaning he
taught them that there's something wrong
with liberalism there's something wrong
with this liberal individualism that's
being given to you and people gravitated
to that then what did he do he joined
the daily wire and he took trips to
Israel and was pictures of him having
dinner with Ben Shapiro and and Benjamin
Netanyahu and then he was given these
Fallen interviews with Netanyahu and now
he's on Twitter saying give them hell
Netanyahu and he's telling people we
need to go after Iran he's pushing this
Zionist propaganda and it's like you can
go down the list of all of these big
conservative influencers that were that
are propped up the editor of Breitbart
people might be familiar with britbe
this was a publication that became very
popular during the kind of first Trump
movement and it does represent that kind
of populist trumpist energy um the
editor of it is is a guy called Joel
Pollock and he came on Twitter after
taking a break for for the Sabbath he
came on on the
weekend uh and he said that Gaza needs
to be flattened people there need to be
wiped out so I think clearly his
identity his loyalty is more to Israel
than than to un to the United States
because he's never made statements that
strong about secure in America's borders
but he's very concerned about securing
Israel's borders and you can even look
up you can still find this
online Breitbart there's a headline that
says breitbard um founded in America
made in Israel and there's a picture of
the founders of Breitbart in Israel in a
meeting with Benjamin Netanyahu and the
the con the idea for britbe was
literally like conceived and planned in
Israel and I can keep going through the
list we have even you look at like the
intellectual influences on the right
like I said there was this kind of
populist trumpus movement brexit all
this kind of stuff was happening in
2016 and there was this question like
where where is this energy going to go
because Trump was certainly in his
rhetoric I mean as president he was as
Zionist as any president but his
rhetoric he talked about things like
ending these Foreign Wars and there was
a I think there was a mood of that let's
move away from the Neo conservatism
let's move towards America first uh not
getting involved in these foreign
entanglements but what happened you had
this thing called National conservatism
appear and this was going to be the new
philosophy of of the right in the
west and you have all of these people
like uh Victor Orban and and tuer Carson
speak at at the conferences for National
conservatism well who runs the National
conservatism it's learned by this thing
called The burky Institute by a guy
called yuram honei who wrote this book
the virtues of nationalism and he was
kind of telling people in the west okay
you can have a little bit of nationalism
you can have a bit of your own identity
but he also had a big defense of Zionism
in that book and he's a he works in
Israel he's a university Professor
living in Israel and he's telling people
in the west this is how your nationalism
should be this is how you're allowed to
be conservative and TI Zionism so the
question is like why are we in the west
why do we need a guy in Israel to work
out this philosophy of of what it means
to be a a western or to what it means to
be a nationalist in the west uh why do
we have Ben Shapiro telling
conservatives in America to send their
money to a foreign country but it's like
you go down the list I mentioned breb
again you can look this up the their
current uh one of the the men editors
there or rather the sorry I'm confused
I'm thinking of Prager University and
Prager which is this big Channel you may
have seen on YouTube and again it's one
of the biggest uh influencers of
conservative discourse they get millions
of views on their videos they kind of
teach young people this is what it means
to be conservative this is what it means
to to be on the ride and they have
multiple videos like defending the IDF
defending Israel this is why you have to
support Israel their CEO literally
worked for Israeli intelligence I mean
she's literally like an Israeli
intelligence spy so this is who's
controlling this centralized astroturfed
conservative movement in the west and
now I can go on there and I can rescue
these people and I get 30 million views
in a week um and you know I'm just a guy
with you know just people that enjoy my
content support me I have no
institutional support and there are
people like that out there you know
there's the America first movement and
they they're young Zoomers that reject
this stuff but we just people like that
just get censored so brutally to prop up
these astr Turf figures prer you the
daily wire breit B and like I said you
go through each one of them and it's
there there's always you can trace it
back and there's an Israeli firster at
the top of these organizations we can't
have a proper conversation about
anything in the west while this is going
on because it always gets directed back
towards this state in the Middle
East uh people can go to um there's a
good Ted talk if you type in uh Ted Talk
and astroturfing I recommend people look
into this because it's um it's real
important human life is precious life
this is something that um is very very
important doesn't matter if
it's from a child from from one side or
the other you know these are innocent
human lives uh that are being lost and
it seems like every time this discussion
have you noticed via be appears Morgan
VI it be um on any one of these um news
channels the first thing they want to
get into is having the the Muslim the
one who's there trying to speak up and
on this they right away are pulling this
uh do you condemn the of course we
condemn killing of innocent uh human
beings this is something clear but then
they shift the focus to talk but uh in
another Direction and they don't do the
same thing if somebody from the IDF or
somebody on this side comes out they
don't ask them to condemn the the
indiscriminate bombing of what is it
like 50% are is it 50% are almost like
children in in gazra you got children
almost for young children as well Young
children I mean they're innocent they
have nothing to to it's just incredible
as well because I've SE I mean I've lost
count this week of how many zionists
I've seen on on Twitter effectively
justifying genocide they I mentioned
Joel Pollock the the senior editor of
britbe in level Gaza these people come
on and and they're supposedly
conservatives that are supposed to be
concerned about the west and they're
they're making these arguments like
everyone in Gaza is collectively
responsible for Hamas we need to glass
Gaza just wipe it out they're talking
about wiping out 2 million people that
are that are confined to the space and
this is like the most extreme kind of
discourse imaginable where you can
literally come on social media and
advocate for genocide I mean what could
be what could be more extreme than that
we hear all these terms like hate speech
and why we need to silence the internet
because of white supremacy well you have
these Zionist ethnic supremacists on
social media freely advocating genocide
as a form of racial Revenge but then you
have you know you have conservatives you
someone like Nick Fuentes he's he's
censored okay he said some controversial
things you could find the most
controversial stuff he said he's never
advocated genocide in an entire people
but somehow this is accepted it doesn't
make any sense in in the terms that
these people treat the rest of our
politics like I said Jonathan Green blad
he's the main person responsible for
censorship his Anti-Defamation League uh
which is a explicitly Jewish activist
group and he is is trying to censor
people for prettyy moderate beliefs he
led this advertising boycott of of
Twitter when Elon Musk took over that
Elon has said now cost Twitter 60% of
its advertising revenue and he did this
to try and force them to censor voices
mostly anti-zionist voices but he's
going on TV now and he's saying that
this is uh this is the worst thing
happened since
Nagasaki um he's defending this this
Zionist far government while he pushes
you know far left woke beliefs in the
West there'll be no statement from the
ADL condemning the the people that
marched in New York with Israeli Flags
saying we need to wipe out Gaza but they
did do a big huge research article about
the fact that there was some uh there
was some nationalists uh there was some
far right people uh in the West on
telegram that were sympathetic to Hamas
that's the big Focus but the fact that
you have actual Jewish supremacists that
are openly telling cameras they're
genocidal and they want to wipe out
Arabs that gets a
pass here's um many have uh quoted uh
this defense minister saying I've
ordered a Complete Siege on the Gaza
Strip there will be no electricity no
food no fuel everything is closed we are
fighting Human animals so this goes back
into like now
dehumanizing children human beings and
let's just go ahead and take a take a
look when you do that that then you make
the other side look like they're just
barbarians and you try to take that
human element away from it and now
there're there's no feeling for what's
happening and people can let's look at
some of these videos I mean this is just
a man now he's
sitting his his
[Music]
whole my house my
um everything is pretty much gone this
is um an aerial view of this I believe
is Gaza is that right yeah and even I
mean that this is the justification what
does that mean can you can you UNP
package that because some people they
don't get these terms these word okay
what does that mean it's just like
they're barricaded in this area you got
how many was like almost two million
people yeah more it's like 2.2 million I
believe and they're stuck they can't
leave they so everything's been they're
stuck there so this is like and it's not
just that things can get out things
can't get in right like I said this is 5
miles wide 25 mil long 2 million people
packed into that tiny space um and it's
a it's a brutal blockade they have this
noo Zone around the area that if you
step into it uh Israeli soldiers will
fire on you um people get killed every
year for for going into that area the
sea is also blockaded and in the past a
few years ago there was a humanitarian a
ship that tried to send Aid to Gaza that
was fired on by Israeli Commandos in the
SE
and they've enforced these these brutal
blockades so one of them was when people
were flying kites over the walls into
Israel these like fire kites uh that
actually didn't do that much damage to
Israel it was basically an act of
desperation by by young people in in
Gaza but they imposed this brutal
blockade where they weren't allowing in
really essential supplies like you
couldn't transport things like plasters
and medical equipment um so they're
totally blockaded it is an open air
prison uh According to some estimate 60%
of the population is unemployed and
that's been the case for decades there
so these people are really in a totally
hopeless position and yeah I've seen
zionists this is how they justify it
they say we gave them a day to evacuate
the women and children so now
effectively anyone that's there deserves
their fed if they get hit with a Israeli
rocket you know if our soldiers going
and and clean house it's like where are
they meant to evacuate to 2.1 million
people locked in this and this
effectively a concentration camp but
this is like I said this stuff is
normalized I mean I saw a member of the
Israeli Kess that was saying that every
person that lives in Gaza is guilty
there are no civilians I saw another one
who's a member of the ruling L could
party was advocating uh using a what he
called a doomsday weapon and firing a
Jericho missile into Gaza which would
just wipe
out massive region kill hundreds of
thousands of people but again this is
the kind of of supremacist attitudes
that are normal in Israel this Jewish
supremacism amongst this ruling party
where you'll just get elected
politicians casually talking about
genocide in these people and yeah it's
it's very jaring to
see I like how you differentiate because
this is not a Jewish Muslim thing you
have Christian Christians who are there
as a Palestinian Christian I have many
problem with Christian Zionist uh first
of all this is an ideology that
completely ignored me and ignored my
people and to a certain degree even
dismissed us and dehumanized US speaking
about an empty land or uh uh Palestine
as a land without a people that is
dehumanizing to our presence uh if you
believe that God brought the Jews to
this land and they have a divine right
to this land and this is fulfillment of
Prophecy then what about me what should
I do should I just leave should I pack
and leave is this what you are proposing
in other words this is an ideology that
completely ignored our presence and even
uh dismissed that presence many times
they would tell us go to Jordan many
times they would say there is no such a
thing as a Palestinian other times they
will even say we are an obstacle to the
second coming uh of Christ and in that
process they have ignored our rights and
maybe my uh one of my biggest problem
with Christian Zionism is that it is the
void of Justice because what about the
current military occupation Tower land
and to our people what about the many
injustices and the discriminative laws
of the state of Israel towards uh
Palestinians I mean it's a state that
says that the right for
self-determination is exclusive to the
Jewish people only how can you as a
Christian support that what about the
rights of refugees to returns or about
land uh when you confiscate land from
Palestinian families sometimes
Palestinian Christian families to build
a Jewish settlement uh on that on that
land can how can you be as a Christian
okay with that with that action you
mentioned the spitting on Christians you
mentioned the treatment of Christians
even there in this area uh so this is
not something that is you know you have
a a long history where before this I've
had rabbis on many Jews believe wrongly
that Zionism is either part of Judaism
or is compatible with Judaism or is even
the main part of Judaism all of those
are actually
false zionis was created to negate
Judaism Zionism was created to replace
Judaism the differences between Zionism
and Judaism are vast they're vast and
profound the propaganda that the
zionists have churned out for the past
100 years have confused and conflated
Zionism and Judaism such that when the
average person walks down the street he
thinks that the state of Israel is the
Jewish State he thinks that Zionism is
Judaism and he doesn't know the
difference this group of Jews here are
students of the students of the late
satma Rabbi RAB tidle bam who was the
greatest disseminator of the clarity
regarding the difference between Judaism
and Zionism we met with we go to Muslim
countries aans because it's a
requirement as the chief Rabbi of
Palestine Rabbi tidle bound said we are
required to let the world know that
these zionists and their state does not
speak for the Jewish people and they are
not um um in any way have the right to
use Judaism to oppress to steal the land
from the Palestinian people uh these
people who are good to us and we Babys
at each other's children we live
together they have no right to steal
from them the Torah doesn't permit you
to steal Zionist wants to confuse to
make it that there a religious conflict
nothing to do with religion on the
contrary the Muslims and the Arab people
were for us our friends and our patrons
the ones who protect us and provide a
safe haven and they should should not be
full full victim of this evil movement
of Zionism with God's help if you remove
this impediment to peace Zionism a new a
relatively new ideology so 100 m years
then the Jews and Muslims and Christians
were living for hundreds and hundreds of
years and it was never a problem I had
um also um I don't know if you heard of
Miko PID Rabbi who lived in jeruselam he
was one of the anti-zionist rabbis like
like Rabbi Weiss that you interviewed
and he was interviewed by a student of
his and the student said to him if um uh
if you were in charge today what will be
the first thing that you would do and
this Rabbi said the first thing I would
do is I would ask the Palestinians to
come back and the student says why what
are you talking about they're terrorists
they want to kill us and the rabbi his
name is Rabbi amam Rabbi amram Blau and
the rabbi said who told you that who
told you that the Arabs were going to
kill us we had great relations with the
Muslims and the Arabs back in the day
you know his family lived in Hebron and
his half family lived in Jerusalem that
always had you know Jewish minorities he
said we had great relations we share the
same values we Shar the similar culture
you know we all treat each other with
respect it was only only when the
zionists came the beginning of the 20th
century that the terrorism began that
the violence began and it was initiated
not by the Palestinians not by the Arabs
and the Muslims but by the Zionist
Israeli also Jewish who's also speaking
out against this and he talks about like
many that Jews Christians and Muslims
were actually living in this part of the
world they were living there for
centuries in peace and it's not until
recently until this was started
happening that this land was um stolen
and now you have all these injustices
that are that are happening that now
this is causing what's what's erupting
in this part of the the world it's very
sad to see you know that that clip you
played at the beginning Gabor mate he's
he's very critical of Israel you have
people like Norman felstein one of the
most influential academics who's who's
Jewish who's critical of Israel n chsky
Elan Pape who wrote a book the ethnic
cleansing of Palestine that's kind of
the authoritative book on on the nakba
um so yeah it's not it's not a question
of all Jews but it is an issue of there
is this ideology of Jewish
supremacism that is very common within
the Israeli government within this farro
liic government and Within These
extremist talmudic groups like the temp
Institute who this guy represented says
that Israel is fighting Orcs guys are
worshiping one
Jew that's a mistake you should be
worshiping every single one of us
because the Jewish people in the land of
Israel are the bul workk against the
Orcs And says that everyone outside what
are Orcs what what are
Orcs Orcs as in you know the the kind of
ghoulish monsters from Lord of the Rings
that's how he refers non-jews in in in
the the podcast he was on and he says
that all all non-jews should worship
Jewish people collectively why why
explain this to me I I cannot wrap my
head around this um because uh Muslims
we love and rever Jesus uh as one of the
mightiest Messengers um we can't say one
disrespectful thing about him when we
say Jesus we say peace be upon Him
obviously we don't agree that he's God
or literal Son of God we believe like in
the Bible he's called a prophet he's a
messenger that's a different discussion
debate but I'm what I'm saying here is
that we we have uh such respect for his
Blessed Mother Mary medium there's a
whole chapter in the Quran named after
her okay my point my point is why why is
there such a connection now here with
this other group who disrespects Jesus
who talks you know evil about his mother
and now you have Christians I believe
what is it like uh how what's the
percentage wise of Christians who are
actually zionists now and they've taken
like Muslims almost as the enemy and
they're over here you know getting spit
on disrespected and whatnot and uh we
love peace for all for all of all of us
you know to work together on many of the
common things that we have in in common
but this just doesn't it doesn't like
make sense to me you know that you have
these Evangelical Christians who are who
are out there and they're uh propping
this up and helping helping this uh to
happen must of these injustices and what
are your thoughts what on this why why
is this yeah it it doesn't make sense
that you have these people telling us
that the the ultimate conflict is is
Christianity versus Islam I mean like
you said Jesus is is revered as a
prophet in Islam if you look at what the
talmud which is what these people follow
you know they have a lot of religious
books it's the Torah isn't their main
book it's the the Babylonian talm mod
and if you look at the talmud what it
says about Jesus is um you know is uh we
don't have to get into it but people can
we don't have to get into it but what
you're talking would be an
understatement right but yeah
unfortunately you have these Christian
zionists that think they have to fulfill
this prophecy by by by uh giving these
these talmudic Jews a Homeland in Israel
and and by supporting any kind of
oppressive action they do against
Palestinians um now there's an
interesting history on that you know
there was the so-called scoffield
reference Bible that was made very
popular in the US after the first world
war that had a lot of this
dispensational stuff about you know how
history's broken down into eras and it's
necessary to bring about this this
Jewish state in the Middle East and
people are kind of hopped up on this
stuff now that's not common theology in
in Catholicism or Orthodoxy but it has
spread in a lot of these Evangelical
churches and again you know I would
suggest if you look into the history of
that and why that spread and why the SC
from the Scofield from that I I heard
something about this this kicked off
with the SC Scofield bible yeah and
again I'd suggest you know if you look
at the the the kind of interest that
promoted that and wanted Christians to
embrace that you know again it's these
Zionist influences that certainly want
to have Christians under their thumb
like that but yeah I mean theologically
historically it doesn't make any sense I
mean there was a a pope I don't know was
it Benedict the 15th it was one one of
the popes that said the Holy Land could
never belong to to modern day Jews and
you know if you look at Christian
theology I mean Israel the people of
Israel Jesus brought about the New
Covenant so Israel is supposed to be uh
that's the Covenant that Jesus brought
about that would be if you're Catholic
Israel is the Catholic church it's not
this state in the Middle East that is
this Zionist political entity that you
have to support of of um people that
deny Christ so it doesn't make any sense
like theologically
historically um it's very much again we
talk about AstroTurf this is very much a
modern phenomenon it's very much tied to
to the US and their support for Israel
um but unfortunately this has captured a
lot of people but I do think a lot of
Christians are waking up to this I hear
I think that's what I was going to say
I've see a lot of Christians who are
pushing back and waking other Christians
up about this yeah yeah if if you look
at young people if you look at the
trends with young people um like I said
there are a lot of people in the west
that are tired of liberalism and looking
for something more
meaningful um and I think you you see
that even with things like the
popularity of of the Tate brothers and
even Jordan Peterson when he was popular
um but if you look at the trends like
young people that go back to
Christianity it tends more to be um more
illiberal like Catholicism Orthodoxy
something that has more of a tradition
and also if you look at support for
Israel it's very much a kind of
generational thing the Boomer is
definitely big supporters of Israel and
the us but as you go down as you go down
to generations and you get to the
younger conserv atives they're very much
ambivalent about Israel and that's a
concern for Israel because uh you know
they ho the left up on this
anti-colonialism stuff um now that
they're opposed to Israel for that
reason and there's a lot of uh first
second generation immigrants in the west
that are oppos to Israel so they need
the support of the Republican Party
specifically they need support of
conservatives but if you go down to the
younger generation of conservatives and
I think the internet has a lot to do
with it and and you know being able to
get these narratives out there about how
Israel hasn't been friend to the US uh
you see that support begins to collapse
and you see that conservatives of the
younger generation are much more
nationalistic they're much more America
first they don't understand these
generational conflicts and why the US
should be involved in the Middle East so
if you look under the surface you know
there are ways in which these
traditional sources of support the
Christian Zionism the Republican Party
they're slowly getting undermined by
being able to spread narratives and
being able to to speak freely the
internet has had a lot to do with that M
uh we got a few more minutes uh I want
to just touch upon this is a longer
discussion I actually spoke about this
uh some time ago about this uh Third
Temple it was something that was kind of
like oh this conspiracy and this that
and the other but this is what you were
pointing out this is becoming more
mainstream now is that correct uh with
this uh with the political party that's
now in place they're actually trying to
um go ahead and build build this Temple
where is it at right now what's the
where where they at now it's obviously
very uh it's a very touchy subject for
everyone the Christians and the Muslims
and the Jews so the the Israeli
government won't come out and say like
yeah we're going to demolish the mosque
and build a temple I mean that would
really set things off right especially
when they're trying to normalize
relations which but this is something
people can go look into right this is
not something that uh oh yeah I mean you
can just look up the temple Institute
and you know the the quotes I was
pulling from where the guy was calling
people Orcs And saying everyone needs to
to worship Jewish people that guy that's
on his official podcast Rabbi Kim
Richmond okay can look that up and he
was head of the temple Institute for 30
years and this is all documented they
even have a lab in in in Texas I believe
where they're they're work so people can
verify this this is something oh yeah
yeah they're working with embryo
selection to to breed this red calf that
they have to sacrifice on the Temple
Mount and then they can build this this
third Temple and you can just find
multiple statements from people that
have held very high positions in the
Israeli government like I said the
Israeli government might not come out
and say yeah we support this because
that would just declare them an enemy to
all Muslim and Christians alike but you
can find statements from Individual
ministers where they say like
aspirationally yes in the long run we
would like to see the Third Temple build
yes that's how we'll know when when the
Zionist project has succeeded this kind
of thing um and these are the groups you
know this attack by Hamas was called the
alaa flood because in their statement
they released they said it was a
response to the raise intentions related
to alaa Masque and what was kicking this
off and again you can find all of this
verified is these talmudic extremist
groups were storming Alexa mosque
forcing worshippers out they're
declaring to the Muslims we're going to
tear this down we're going to build the
Third Temple uh you can find this
footage they're telling that the Arabs
there's going to be a second knocko um
so these are the groups that are driving
this it's this supremacist ideology
where these people think that they
should be worshiped think that they're
the center of History you know they
don't believe that the Covenant is is
For All Mankind they believe that it's
about them and that they have a right to
extinguish other people's holy sites and
Destroy uh other people's places of
worship to bring this about and you know
like I said if there were a fringe cult
it would be one thing but when they have
support within the Israeli government I
think it it shows how extreme this
sanist project has
become recently we had um the one of the
discussions of the year on the uh
Patrick M David Pockets I went down
there myself I met Patrick and uh I
would really recommend that he gets if
he wants to talk and dwell into these
topics he talks a lot about politics and
others would you be willing to go on I
would recommend that Patrick B David he
has a vision of Muslims and Christians
working together on a common good on the
things that we have in common I'm really
I really respect this vision and I
really agree with it we have a lot of
things in common and we have many things
that are affecting ourselves our
families our communities and now we have
these things that are now um a point of
contention and I think uh you've made
some really really important points and
what would you say to someone like
Patrick bavid and others a lot of he has
a huge Christian following and others um
I make this example I had also a
Christian who was a huge uh hater of
Islam and Muslims I don't know if you've
heard of Owen Benjamin my main thing is
to help people not hate so many
good-hearted Muslims that are W
withstanding evil and they are the type
of people you you want to root for the
scolly beautiful Muslim people don't let
the media paint you know a fifth of the
planet is people that deserve to be
bombed as a sacrifice so we want to we
want to help with that we want to help
because there's a lot of lot of hate out
there and go ahead yeah there's a lot of
programming that I've realized has
happened in America of the anti-muslim
programming because we all know there's
Pharisees in every religion there's some
bad Muslims some bad Christians and bad
Jews everything because I used to think
that Muslims were the boogeyman
something that really changed my
perspective was when a Muslim friend of
mine I heard him say Jesus peace be upon
him and I had always thought that you
guys hated Jesus you know and that was
and that blew my mind because I listen
to Ben Shapiro on Joe Rogan talk about
how Jesus Christ was um a common
criminal and was killed for rebelling
against Rome which is this insane
statement and then my Muslim friend
would say Jesus peace be upon him and I
was like huh that kind of made it
through the programming and once he
started to see like wow Muslims they say
when they say Jesus they say turns of
respect peace be upon him you know they
don't disrespect him but this other
group and then he was like man you know
when he started to really investigate he
saw like he was he was uh programmed and
he got unprogrammed and I think many of
these people listening to people like
yourself you know giving much of the
facts de debunking much of the atrocity
propaganda that's out there what would
you say to PE someone like would you go
on a pdb podcast would you sit and talk
with um with Patrick V David and and
many of his followers that are out there
if they're confused right they're
confused you know they they don't agree
with3 billion dollar we have homeless
people we have sick people we have
communities that look like they've been
worn torn in our country and we're I'm
an American also my my I was born here I
want the best for my country uh I don't
want our money being thrown out when we
have issues here most Americans I had a
Christian lady also uh from uh if
Americans only knew if they only knew
they wouldn't agree with all this money
how much is it three billion a year
going going out 3.8 billion it's it's
actually more if you look into imagine
what we what we can do with that money
here right so what would you say to the
average Christian and other people who
there people are being programmed in the
wrong direction what would you say to
them and where would you direct them to
get the proper education on this matter
here well I would just repeat that the
conversation in the west is very
centrally controlled by figures that are
very focused on this one specific topic
you know I come at this first and
foremost from the the position of of a
of a nationalist I value like real real
cultural ethnic religious diversity and
and you know I want to preserve my
identity and you know I'm getting a lot
of of Muslim followers now because I'm
take that to its logical conclusion I
say well you know I want an Ireland for
the Irish and I think Palestinians
should have Palestine and they shouldn't
have to be forced out of their Homeland
um and you know a lot of them they see
oh well you know you you you're taking
this kind of uh nationalist stance in
the west you must be anti-islam you know
you must support these wars in the
Middle East it's like no of course not
you know people in in the west we want
to be left alone we want to have our own
cultures and traditions it's not us
that's pushing this it's these Zionist
figures that have that have captured the
conversation it went through all of the
the lists of of big influencers and we
get redirected all of the time if if
people in the west are concerned about
losing their identity and culture and if
they want to preserve that if they do
something like oppose immigration they
get distracted they say no the problem
is actually Islam and we need to reform
Islam you know this was popular you had
these figures like Tommy Robinson where
he was first he was representing people
that were concerned about
multiculturalism and then he said
actually the problem is Islam and Islam
needs a reformation and we need to make
the Muslims good liberals and feminists
and then everything will be fine and so
he he puts people and these figures put
us normal westerners in opposition to
Muslims as if we have to do this
Imperial project to to change other
people's religion um just because we
want to preserve our traditions and
identities so the conversation is
totally manipulated if there were people
that could actually Express that and
could actually Express a proper if even
if you look at the us if someone
expressed a proper America First
Position they say why are we supporting
Israel when it Bond the USS Liberty an
American ship uh why are we supporting
Israel when it's creating all these
enemies for us when you know the
previous Terror attacks on the US have
have been justified by their ongoing
support for parti stad in Israel so I
think if if there was a proper
conversation If people could have an
open dialogue about this things would
turn very quickly and that's what you
have to keep in mind this are a very
powerful interest I work very hard and
throw a lot of money into control in
this conversation um as far as where to
look I mean you can follow me on on
Twitter you'll find the people I retweet
there are still some good voices out
there you know I was banned of Twitter
for for a year and a half so like I said
it's we get suppressed hard but you can
follow me Jake Shields is a good example
these are guys that were pushing the the
Bandy ADL tag as well trying to end this
the Zion a censorship of the internet
Lucas Gage is another one who uh I
repost a lot um and you know we are out
there there are people that uh care
about the West want to preserve our
Traditions our identities but see that
the problem is not Islam or the problem
is not any individual people the problem
is this supremacist Zionist ideology
that controls our discourse and then
creates this destabilized creat these
wars and this destabilization in the
Middle
East waking people up about that and you
have I've interviewed a lot of uh Jews
rabbis and whatnot I said earlier who
also who make this distinction and who
are against this same movement Jews
themselves yeah yeah so you're down for
the pbd podcast if uh absolutely AB
let's get everybody who's watching send
this uh go ahead and retweet this send
this to our friend uh Patrick uh B David
and he can have another fair and
balanced discussion with somebody like
you who's very well informed I want to
thank you very much God bless you for
being with us and um helping to share
much of this these this information as
very important God bless and thanks for
having me on thank you brother thank you
peace we've been told that uh they're
out to kill us all Salam Alum brothers
and sisters we went to the streets to
ask Americans about Islam here's what
they said do you know anything about
Islam No do you know anything about
Islam No sadly do you know anything
about Islam uh not really do you know
anything about
Islam No sorry you know what Islam means
Islam uh no we've been told that uh
they're out to kill us all that's what
you've been told that Muslims are out to
kill you all well let's say say on TV
anything I know it's in the Middle East
is it well then you can have four wives
brothers and sisters as you can see
there are so many Americans who don't
know about Islam we need your help to
change that help us to build the dean
Center the first Mega daa Center in
America click to donate right now may
God Almighty Allah reward all of
you not leave without giving you a gift
if you're not yet Muslim and you're
tuning in to see what these Muslims are
talking about and you like a free copy
of the Quran go ahead and visit theen
show.com we'll take care of the postage
and everything and get it delivered to
you and if you still have some questions
about Islam call us at 18006 62 4752
we'll see you next time until then peace
be with you assalam alaykum